alireza first of all congratulations an
incredible performance for you today how
do you assess this result and what did
you do to prepare for uh such a day
yeah i'm very happy with my performance
um
i think
continuing zagreb it was a
it was a good progress because the first
day of zagreb it was very bad but the
second day was the same as here so
um yeah in the blitz you should really
have the day so
i was lucky that i was in a good mood
today
and
yeah it was a very good performance i
guess
you also never lost touch with that
leadership position starting after day
one you were maybe close with mvl but
never lost touch with that leadership
position was that part of your strategy
and was that important for you yeah of
course it's important to keep the
leadership but the worst the there is of
course
bad thing about being leader all the
rounds is that everybody's looking at
you who wants to
catch you in the playing how they look
a little bit
strange to me but
yeah in general i think it's difficult
to handle the lead in this kind of
tournaments but i'm happy that i managed
until here so but there is nine rounds
to go for
absolutely still nine rounds to go a
very hot hikaru nakamura did you expect
to see hikaru heat up like that
yeah of course i was expecting this
that's why i wanted to
get a big lead in the rapid for from him
because he's always
putting these kind of performances in
blitz so
yeah i'm not shocked i think he's
world number one in blitz i think number
two so number one yeah number one so
it's pretty normal i guess still nine
rounds to go we'll let you go get some
rest congratulations we'll see you
tomorrow
our congratulations as well a very very
nice performance only overshadowed just
a little bit